[Musique]
pour en parler nous sommes en direct
avec sait bien que de ville médecin
généraliste à l'origine du hashtag je ne
confierais pas christian baulme
président de l'association dès
commerçants et artisans des métropoles
de france enfin pierre jean ternat bihan
président de l'union régionale des
professionnels de santé les médecins
libéraux d'auvergne un ronald bonsoir
messieurs bonsoir à tous les trois et
merci d'être en direct sur rt france
alors l'information du soir à nous
viendrait de nos confrères france info
qui affirme que contrairement aux
informations données par d'autres médias
emmanuel macron ne parlerai pas mercredi
finalement ils voudraient attendre de
voir les effets du couvre feu généralisé
à 18 heures c'est un soulagement
temporaire fabien coddeville oui que
notre action a eu permis la réflexion
comme comme on le souhaitait un je
rappelle que ce n'est pas une appel à la
désobéissance civile mais parfois il
faut utiliser des formules un petit peu
un petit peu chocs pour pour stimuler le
débat est on est on est ravi en tout cas
que le débat puisse être posée sur le
sur le sur le confinement
idem pour vous soulagement temporaire
mais mais prudence du côté des
entreprises des commerçants christian
baulme écouter oui en sachant que une
prise de décision après avoir annoncé qu
on attendait 15 jours si on la prend
cinq jours en avant il faut que les
chiffres donnent raison à cette prise de
décision aujourd'hui c'est pas tout à
fait ce qu on entend même si les indices
ne sont pas très bon et on entend bien
la difficulté des politiques à aller
contre le sentiment des français qui en
ont plein les bottes on va dire les
choses comme elles sont je vous parle
pas des commerçants qui eux n'ont qu'un
seul espoir ne pas fermer alors on sait
très bien que confiné s'enfermer le
commerce et c'est illusoire mais en tout
cas que ça soit fait avec discernement
avec équité surtout de l'équité de
traitement entre le commerce
traditionnel et la grande distribution
voilà il faut maîtriser les flux dans la
grande distribution notamment avec un
virus beaucoup plus dangereux en termes
de contamination jusqu'à preuve du
contraire les commerçants ne sont pas un
lieu de contamination donc nous nous
attendons un confinement le plus tard
possible parce que nous avons besoin de
vider les stocks des collections d'hiver
et c'est impératif pour la survie
économique des commerçants notamment
dans le prêt-à-porter alors
manifestement emmanuel macron vous
entend tout de même parce que toujours
selon les confrères de france info il
voudrait tout faire pour éviter ce
confinement vous venez de dire un
confinement de plus en plus tard
possible plus tard possible
sauf que dans le même temps 1 pour
reprendre une expression chère au
président il y a près de 20000 quatre
quotidiens de contamination plus de 3000
personnes en réanimation tous les
indicateurs clairement sont inquiétants
ni jean castex qui promet des décisions
cette semaine est ce que ce n'est pas
pire d'attendre avec une situation peut
être encore pire si j'ose dire avec ce
variant qui se diffuse davantage en
france clergé en interne amiens je pense
qu'on est de nouveau en retard dans les
dents les mesures apprend on à la région
clairement on a une accélération due
de décès ou une à une accélération
inexpliquée sur des départements qui
pour l'instant été épargnée et qui sont
à faible population pour l'instant c'est
à dire la drôme l'ardèche la haute loire
qui jusqu'à présent était passé à
travers les mailles du filet et ça monte
en flèche
ça monte en flèche aussi sur les
nouvelles d'hospitalisation pas encore
ea on sait très bien qu'on a on va dire
à une traîne de dix jours derrière pour
se retrouver avec des règles qui vont
être saturé et on est à pratiquement à
90% de lits occupés en animation en
auvergne rhône-alpes donc la marge de
manoeuvre est très faible et je pense
que plus les jours passent alors je suis
pas partisan personnellement en rien
d'un confinement strict mais clairement
les mesures qu'on avait discuté sur
votre plateau en octobre c'est à dire un
confine un couvre-feu beaucoup plus
sévère
beaucoup plus étendue y compris les
week-ends tout en permettant aux gens de
dalé parce que le français qui
travaillent cinq jours par semaine j'en
ai lu chan connais pas beaucoup moins
avec la semaine des 35 heures donc on a
quand même une journée de liberté pour
pouvoir faire nos courses aller chez nos
commerçants est effectivement peut-être
donner un peu d'oxygène parce que on est
à plus de 122 % de dette de pipes et ça
devient intenable c'est mes enfants mes
petits enfants à venir qui vont payer
une dette incommensurable qu'en pense le
médecin vous êtes également fabien que
de vie quand vous entendez votre
confrère nous dire c'est de pire en pire
il ya de plus en plus de monde en
réanimation il ya une augmentation des
décès dans certaines régions ce variant
il ne vous inquiète pas plus que ça
après il faut reprendre aussi de façon
factuelle les chiffres et si on vous
regarde pas sûr sur le terrain en
médecine de ville en consultation mai
2006 on reprend les indicateurs par
exemple du réseau sentinelles on voit
qu'on a des tea dance d'infections
respiratoires acolytes qui sont faibles
puisque la semaine dernière en semaine 2
on était à en était à 19,4 pour cent
mille habitants
rappelle que les épidémies ou pandémies
démarre et au pic de l'épidémie ces 300
à 500 cas peut-être qu'il ya des
départements qui sont plus touchés mais
si on prend les données nationales
c'est ce qui se passe si on prend les
données des sceaux est ce médecin est
également les consultations étaient pour
suspicion de que vides étaient en baisse
alors il y a forcément en hiver il ya
toujours des remontées des
hospitalisations et d admission en
réanimation mais il faut bien peser
surtout le risque d'un confinement le
risque d'un confinement on l'a connu au
mois de mars et au mois d'avril le
confinement à entraîner et entraîne des
effets collatéraux considérables et il
faut pas oublier à la fois pour les
patients dont je vois beaucoup on sait
aujourd'hui que le confinement à des
effets psychiques extrêmement sévère on
parle de la santé mentale des étudiants
et des jeunes qui ce qui est
catastrophique aujourd'hui il y a aussi
nié des personnes âgées autonomes qui
sont isolées des gens qui nichent par
n'est pas mais qui vivent habituellement
normalement qui vont très mal je vois
beaucoup beaucoup de gens déprimés
aujourd'hui et il faut vraiment peser
outre le coût économique
ça c'est vraiment aussi une vraie
question est ton en mesure encore de
supporter un nouveau confinement mais il
faut peser vraiment le pour et le contre
les études montrent un confinement n'a
pas d'intérêt sur le ralentissement de
l'épidémie
donc je pense qu'il faut s'appuyer sur
ce qu'on sait faire c'est-à-dire
consulter ensuite d'amener les patients
à consulter les tester les diagnostics
et les traités éventuellement si c'est
nécessaire
continuer de faire ce qu'on fait c'est à
dire l'isolément les patients dans tout
à fait compris qu'il fallait s'isoler
dès les premiers symptômes continuer de
tester les cas contacts et il faut aussi
renforcer je pense la protection des
personnes fragiles et vulnérables
notamment dans les ehpad et on peut pas
aujourd'hui aller visiter quelqu'un en
ehpad
sans être testés alors qu'on peut très
bien
par des têtes antigénique tester les
visiteurs en ehpad pour éviter de
contaminer les gens fragiles pareil à
l'hôpital
je pense qu'il ya une vraie alternative
possible à un confinement qui a un
compte à la fois économique mais aussi
social psychologique qui peut être
extrêmement douloureux non seulement à
court terme à moyen mais aussi à long
terme
je rappelle que quand on présente des
troubles psychiques liés à des
traumatismes comme celui ci notamment
chez les plus jeunes qui vont être
privés d'avenir qui n'ont plus de
perspective aujourd'hui ça peut être
considérablement
ça peut ça peut toucher les gens durable
donc je pense qu'il est important aussi
toujours peser la balance
bénéfice-risque en médecine et le risque
à notre un autre sens nous aux
signataires de la tribune bien plus
élevé que les effets positifs du
confinement
on va la voir votre tribune assez sur
les réseaux sociaux que le nom
confinement prend de l'ampleur avec
justement votre tribune pourquoi nous
devons refuser un troisième confinement
qui a donné naissance au f tag je ne me
confinerait pas ce week end
regardez il faut dans un premier temps
mettre un terme à la politique de la
peur néfaste pour l'état psychique de
l'ensemble de la population toutes
classes d'âge confondues car j'ai en
permanence à vous êtes un confrère
justement qu'une idée pour le nom
confinement côté c'est simple dans ma
région auvergne rhône alpes le nombre
cumulé de personnes décédées cette 1667
donc la vérité des chiffres et les
cruels
on peut faire tout ce qu'on veut dire
que l'art est tout ce qu on veut la
seule chose qui marche quand on a une
pandémie c'est le confinement et un
confinement beaucoup plus dur que ce que
nous avons ou malheureusement entre les
vous promener on va dire à 18h vous
n'avez pas l'impression que les gens
sont chez eux en cours au feu
si on veut vraiment s'en sortir et
pouvoir redémarrer notre économie il
faut mettre le paquet et être beaucoup
plus on va dire volontaire dans
l'application des mesures et barrières
ne font pas très bien respectée parfois
et surtout dans un confinement mais
parce que sinon c'est toute l'économie
française qui va s'écrouler
et ça on ne peut pas on va dire
l'accepter donc professer et on va dire
halte au confinement moi j'écoutais on
est en démocratie tout le monde peut
s'exprimer
la problématique qu'on a c'est le nombre
de décès le nombre de gens qui sont on
va dire si on regarde les courbes c'est
très simple on est exactement même stack
fin juin 2020 on a la même remontée
progressive lé plus rapidement rouvert
un ronald que dans le reste de la france
mais on est exactement sur le même trend
qui va nous conduire à la deuxième vague
de l'automne c'est exactement le jeu et
les chiffres sont conformes aussi par
exemple sur ma région j'ai un taux quand
même d'incidents si orléans covit de 581
sos médecins sur dix mille ac ça
commence à faire beaucoup et il est plus
que probable que le choc va arriver on
va bien d'ici 10-15 jours la question
sur les c est ce que le gouvernement
prenne pour on va dire espéré a touché
les vacances souvenirs scolaires et
éviter on va dire une bannière un
confinement des l'idée ou alors est-ce
qu'il prend ses responsabilités et il y
va fort de manière à éviter on va dire
définitivement mon confrère a raison en
disant il ya des souffrances
psychologiques le problème si vous
voulez c'est que je rappelle qu'il ya
quand même pas mal de personnes dès
qu'ils sont en ehpad qui n'ont toujours
pas pu être vacciné lié on va dire à
l'extraordinaire désorganisation du
système en labeaume raconter tout ce
qu'on veut c'est quand même pas glorieux
au point de vue vaccination et par
conséquent c'est des gens qu'il faut
protéger
je dirais 1% de mobilisation dans 30 %
des cas ils meurent fabien cot dit que
c'est vrai que si emmanuel macron
effectivement ne parle pas mercredi et
nous annonce pas ce confinement on
serait d'une certaine manière en
l'exception française passerait
peut-être pour les plus saines laxiste
en europe la plupart des pays sont sont
confinés aujourd'hui avec d'ailleurs des
des montées de colère on l'a vu au pays
basque ce week-end mais confiné tout de
même oui mais vous avez par exemple oui
fabien quatre villes la parole aussi la
réponse à jean pierre sergent tard
gagnant de choses sur le continent
je redis les études montrent qu'il n'y a
pas d'effet du confinement sur le
ralentissement d'une épidémie on l'a vu
récemment terre ou la mise en place du
confinement n'a pas cessé l'épidémie
s'est ralentie naturellement et le
confinement est arrivé après le début du
ralentissement de l'épidémie
donc ça c'est la première chose d'autres
pays de confine pas je vous invite à
regarder les courbes et je vous invite à
regarder date de confinement et vous
verrez et il yad'autres pop et qui n'ont
pas confinés comme la suède la suède n'a
pas confiner leurs appels et la suède à
un taux de mortalité inférieur rapporté
à la population et une épidémie équipe
diminue naturellement sans mesures
restrictives et sans mesures de
confinement
je rappelle une nouvelle fois n'oublions
pas la balance bénéfice risque d'un
traitement peut effectivement nous dit
il faut sauver des vies de gens qui sont
atteints du coc vide mais il ne faut pas
oublier de de ne pas détruire d'autres
vies et je rappelle que vous parliez de
crise économique la crise économique
elle est là la crise et lincoln est dû
non pas au co vide à la crise économique
elle est due à la gestion et les
commerçants peuvent le dire à la gestion
de la crise et au confinement
c'est ça aujourd'hui seuls chez les
médecins à réagir un troisième
confinement suscite pas mal de réactions
politiques également dont celle de la
présidente du rassemblement national ce
matin je vous propose d'écouter marine
le pen avant de vous faire réagir
si nous nous retrouvons dans la
situation d'être obligé de revivre un
confinement c'est je le répète pour la
troisième fois puisque c'est le
troisième confinement dont on parle
c'est qu'on a rarement raté le reste
moi je veux pas me mettre dans la
situation si vous voulez de d'être en
quelques sortes la complice de la
politique du chien crevé au fil de l'eau
qui a été le choix du gouvernement
depuis le début de cette crise sanitaire
christian baulme vous partagez cet avis
et cette stratégie du stop and go qui
est la plus pénalisée
honte pour vous commerçants artisans
alors tout est pénalisant pour un
commerçant il faut qu'on reste ouvert
avec la liberté de circulation et la
liberté la plus totale
alors on a bien compris quand même que
on savait pas faire grand chose d'autre
quand on est des populations qui ne sont
pas disciplinés
alors si vous êtes allé en ville
samedi vous apercevez qu'il y avait très
peu de monde dans les centres villes
notamment dans les grandes métropoles
par contre dans les centres commerciaux
s'était plaint mais plein donc le france
est incapable de faire le moindre effort
une fois qu'ils y sortie qui lui il n'a
plus peur de rien même si on donne ce
sont les seuls magasins et trouvèrent
n'y a pas de musée il n'y a pas
d'exposition n'ya pas de cinéma alors
que fait le français quand il veut
sortir mais il va au centre commercial
en ce moment et c'est vrai que les
centres commerciaux sont bondés et c'est
assez incroyable je ne vous le fais pas
dire le samedi après midi
surtout quand il pleut alors évidemment
ça si la météo vient en rajouter une
petite couche
voilà c'est pas c'est pas facile mais
j'allais dire le comportement des
français est toujours un peu excessif et
je vous confirme que malgré tout à
bordeaux en tout cas je le constate tous
les soirs à 18h il ya quand même mille
fois moins de monde qu'à des cas 17
heures alors c'est vrai que c'est très
pénalisant pour le commerce
ce qui serait le plus pénalisant pour le
commerce c'est que on nous impose la
fermeture totale
il faut que nous restions ouvert quoi
qu'il arrive alors même si ça ne suffit
pas à gagner de l'argent ça suffit en
tout la maintenir l'état psychologie des
commerçants au bon niveau il faut que
nous ouvrions alors le matin on peut
imaginer venir faire le retrait du col
un collègue du click and collect et
l'après-midi de recevoir les clients sur
rendez nous ça serait le moins pire
c'est ce que nous essayons à travers
notre association nationale le calme
commerces artisans des métropoles de
france
c'est ce que nous négocions avec le
ministère avec des sites pour que il
transmet ce besoin de ne pas fermer au
ministère de la santé car aujourd'hui
c'est quand même
le ministère de la santé qui affamant
les avis les avis médicaux
donc après nous vous laisser les
magasins ouverts on va être heureux 1c
mais j'ai peur que ça soit pas les
solutions retenues
donc voilà il faut trouver un juste
milieu
la crise économique bien oui c'est vrai
que ont fait un choix dans le monde
entier
donc ça doit pas être un choix quand
même si mauvais que ça alors c'est la
manière de votre invité pierre long
terme agnant ce qu'odile christian
baulme c'est pas la solution qu'on va
retenir
concrètement on s'attend à quoi parce
que même si on a alors selon les cas un
sursis un répit pour certains ça veut
dire quoi que un confinement strict
comme celui de mars nous pend au nez où
ça va être un petit peu comme le
deuxième selon vous on n'aura pas le
choix on n'aura pas le choix ça c'est
clair
il faut absolument éviter un conflit
mais je pense que si elle est si on
arrive à faire un couvre feu qui soit on
va dire on va dire respecter à 18h et y
compris le week-end on laisse des gens
aller dans les magasins parce qu'ils
veulent les commerçants les industriels
toutes les filières en ont besoin on a
besoin de se ravitailler on a besoin de
faire des achats
les gens sont tout à fait capables dans
les commerces de respecter les
protocoles sanitaires
je dirais c'est plutôt la population des
fois qu'ils ne les respecte pas alors
que je sais très bien que sur la
majorité des commerces est suivi à la
lettre et ils sont inventifs et il se
réinvente en permanence par contre
clairement de dessiner que maintenant
d'un bouclage on va dire on va dire par
test rsr au niveau des aéroports en
provenance du reste de l'europe est une
aberration sera dû être mis en place
depuis longtemps je vous rappelle qu'au
moins de juin alors qu'il y avait aucun
vols commerciaux et rapatriement
sanitaire d'afrique du nord en craie
avec automatiquement de contamination du
territoire métropolitain sans arrêt aux
frontières ça passait il y avait zéro
test il a fallu attendre presque cette
semaine pour qu'on mette en place des
tests pour éviter que ces gens aillent
mourir en réanimation à lyon où un pagne
et on est en train de refaire la même
erreur c'est à dire comme un temps
infini
prendre des mesures énergiques pour
stopper on va dire la progression d'une
personne n'avait vu arriver moyens la
troisième vague dans le reste de
l'europe et je sais c'est dramatique si
vous voulez on court après la parution
très rapidement s'il vous plaît parce
qu'on arrive vraiment au bout du débat
et c'est compliqué de vous faire parler
longuement tous les trois ce confinement
vous militez compte mais on ne va pas y
échapper
il faut qu'il prenne de quelle forme
s'il y en a un seul on vous très
rapidement merci je pense enfin veiller
il ya une alternative encore on peut y
échapper la preuve jusque emmanuel marc
pointe enfin de réfléchir ça veut bien
dire qu'il ya une hésitation au sommet
de l'exécutif
et il ya vraiment une je pense qu'on en
a réussi à faire bouger un petit peu les
lignes a soulevé le débat de je le redis
de l' avantage bénéfices risques et des
risques importants d'un confinement
parce que si on milite à la fois pour un
confinement strict mais l'ouverture des
commerces j'ai du mal un petit peu à
comprendre ce que c'est qu'un
confinement strict donc si on fait un
compliment c'est que c'est un
confinement strict comme en mars avril
et là effectivement connaît des effets
si c'est un confinement lite on sait pas
très bien quelle quel est l'intérêt donc
non il faut s'appuyer sur ce qu'on sait
faire c'est-à-dire soigner les gens les
recevoir les isoler vais tester
renforcer la protection des personnes
fragiles
il y à d'autres alternatives et il faut
cesser avec cette politique de la peur
permanente qui est en train de détruire
psychologiquement la la population
française merci en tout cas à tous les
trois et on apprend à l'instant qu'une
deuxième nuit d'émeutes a lieu aux
pays-bas avant l'imposition d'un couvre
feu donc c'est à des restrictions qui
passe très mal chez nos voisins merci à
vous